THAT AND A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS.  MR. KOBACH, THANKS
FOR JOINING ME.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> MY PLEASURE.
LIKEWISE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX
NEWS ALERT.
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD, IN
ORANGE COUNTY, CALIFORNIA
HAS VOTED TO JOIN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S LAWSUIT
AGAINST CALIFORNIA AND ITS
SANCTUARY STATE LAW.
SANDRA HUTCHINS IS SHERIFF
OF ORANGE COUNTY AND HAS
FOUGHT THAT LAW BY PUBLICLY
POSTING THE RELEASE TIMES OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT IMMATES.
CALIFORNIA A.G. JAVIER
BECERRA SAID HE MAY HAVE
SHERIFF HUTCHINS ARRESTED
FOR THAT, WATCH.
>> STATE LAW IS STATE LAW.
AND IT'S MY JOB TO ENFORCE
STATE LAW.
I WILL DO SO.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY JURISDICTION,
INCLUDING ORANGE COUNTY,
UNDERSTANDING WHAT STATE LAW
REQUIRES OF THE PEOPLE AND
THE SUBDIVISIONS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
>> DOES THAT MEAN THE
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE SHERIFF
OR ARREST OF THE SHERIFF?
>> I THINK I JUST ANSWERED
THAT OKAY.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
>> Tucker: SHERIFF HUTCHINS
JOINS US TONIGHT.
SHERIFF A LOT OF PEOPLE OPT
EAST COAST ARE JUST WAKING
UP TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE MOVING
TOWARDS A CRISIS HERE.
IS THAT THE WAY IT SEEMS TO
YOU?
>> NO.
IT'S NOT A CRISIS AS A
SHERIFF OF ORANGE COUNTY I
FEEL RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF THE
CITIZENS OF OUR COUNTY.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> SB-54 DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
THAT SO I HAVE STARTED
YESTERDAY POSTING THE NAMES
AND DATES OF RELEASE OF ALL
OF INMATES PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL OF THE
COMMUNITY AND THAT IS WELL
WITHIN THE LAW PROVIDED BY
SB-54.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
WHAT I MEANT BY CRISIS IS
YOU ARE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER OF THE
COUNTY, CHIEF LAW
STATE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
THREATENING TO ARREST YOU.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
ANYTHING LIKE THAT HAPPENING
IN ANY STATE, AT LEAST IN MY
LIFETIME.
>> YEAH, AND I HAVEN'T,
EITHER.
AND I FIND IT INTERESTING.
MAYBE HE BETTER READ SB-54
AGAIN BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
HE UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE LAW
SAYS AND WHAT I'M DOING IS
ENTIRELY WITHIN THE CONFINES
OF THE LAW AND I'M DOING
WHAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT
FOR MY CONSTITUENTS.
IT'S A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE
TO ME.
IT'S NOT ABOUT IMMIGRATION
AT ALL.
IT'S ABOUT INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE COMMITTED VIOLENT
CRIMES.
LET ME JUST GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES OF SOME INDIVIDUALS
WE HAVE HAD TO RELEASE.
HOW ABOUT SEX WITH A MINOR.
CHILD CRUELTY.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, I MEAN, I
DON'T THINK I COULD SLEEP AT
NIGHT KNOWING THAT I HAD LET
SOMEBODY GO AND THEY GO OUT
AND COMMIT ANOTHER CRIME
WITH THOSE KINDS OF CHARGES.